out gunned
surrounded and refusing to surrender all
that remains are hardcore isis members
who seemed determined to die
above coalition jets prowl through the
night skies
helping them towards that end
but even with all this firepower it is
still slow going
this battle could be ended in a matter
of hours
yet it isn't because isis is using human
shields
in the last half an hour very heavy
clashes have broken out between the
syrian democratic forces and the islamic
state
we're hearing airstrikes seeing tracer
fire going and
also mortars as well now to give you an
idea of the geography
is positions are about two kilometers
from this frontline position
now what seems to happen is during the
night the fighting
starts up because in the day
there are still women and children it's
thought inside
and coalition forces want to give them a
chance to
escape if they want to come out
in truth the ragtag remains of the
islamic state
has little fight left in it here its
operatives have been
bombed and starved for weeks now and
cornered in this kill zone
they have nowhere to run this desert
wasteland
is where the cult of isis fled after
their strongholds of raqqa and mosul
fell the streets are full of smashed
buildings
everything has been destroyed
isis now exists with its back against
the wall
on this small scrap of land its fighters
living in tunnels
and under the makeshift tents there may
still be isis families
refusing to leave and maybe even
hostages
during the day when the fighting does
stop
is loyalists can be seen moving around
on motorbikes
but how much longer what's left of is's
proto state can survive
is no longer the question the time of
the so-called caliphate
is over
and that is reflected in the atmosphere
on the front line
the syrian democratic forces have almost
total control
they know their enemies defeat is close
the fight for bagoose has already been
won
in everything but name alex rossi sky
news eastern syria